[Music]
Avengers infinity war directors Joe and
Anthony Russo went out of their way to
implore fans and critics not to spoil
the film's many twists so it's
surprising that we've already learned a
great deal about what might take place
in 2019 s Avengers 4 while some
potential spoilers are just rumors from
questionable sources others are slip-ups
from marvel actors or even appear in
official Marvel publications he has a
look at all the Avengers for rumors and
spoilers leaked so far time-travel
leaked set photos from the filming of
Avengers 4 of shown actors wearing some
vintage outfits namely their costumes
from 2012's first Avengers film in fact
a marvelous even recreated sets from the
film's epic Battle of New York sequence
this has led many to speculate that
Avengers 4 would involve time travel and
that makes sense
we know from Avengers infinity war that
bumped the strange use a time stone to
peer into possible future sunset a kind
of plan in motion and we also know that
in his own film he used the time stones
powers to reverse time and save the
world hey they don't call him the doctor
for nothing Hawkeye will become Ronin
thanks to leaked set photos showing
Jeremy Renner wearing some black and
gold boots under his trench coat it's
all but confirmed that Clint Barton will
shed the Hawkeye moniker and adopt the
Ronin persona and Avengers for something
he did in the comics back in 2007 s New
Avengers issue 30 Renner of course was
infamously missing from Avengers
infinity war after his character took a
plea deal following the events of
Captain America Civil War in order to
protect his family fans are speculating
that when Fano snapped his fingers
Hawkeye's wife and kids were among the
victims leading him to return to action
in his new dark identity Tony Stark
builds his own Infinity Gauntlet the
plot of Avengers infinity war contains
so many shocks and surprises nobody
could possibly have guessed them all yes
an anonymous user on the website 4chan
came pretty damn close correctly
predicting such specific details as a
return of the Red Skull and the fact
that Thanos would sacrifice Gamora to
obtain the soul gem some believe but the
user must have inside sources so people
are paying close attention to the
mysterious users latest batch of rumors
for Avengers for Iron Man reassembles
the Avengers and decides to build his
own Infinity Gauntlet to undo everything
that Fano stared they recruit a man to
help them travel through time and space
using the quantum realm to retrieve the
Infinity stones
different time periods fallows finds out
about their plans and becomes hell-bent
on stopping them the movie revolves
around the relationship between Captain
America and Iron Man this claim seems to
be backed up by set photos showing up
man alongside 2012 era cap or is it
possible the theory is simply based on
the photos to begin with hmm so what
does anonymous claim will happen which
starts do Infinity Gauntlet that you
asked professor Hulk will wield the
stark gauntlet one piece of promotional
art for Avengers 4 has supposedly been
leaked online whether or not it's real
as a matter of speculation but a
potentially interesting detail in the
portrayal of the Hulk who is growing
clothes and looks almost human this
supports fan theories at the internal
battle between Hulk and dr. Bruce Banner
that raged throughout Avengers infinity
war will end it with the two
personalities merging to create
professor Hulk a version of the
character from the comics that combines
banners mind with Hulk's body and
according to 4chan tipster anonymous
professor Hulk plays a vital role in
Avengers 4 pokes of plot centers on
banner and hope finally merging to
become professor Hulk he is the one that
ultimately wheels the star gauntlets
against Thanos
losing his arm in the process the death
of Steve Rogers the death of Steve
Rogers has been rumored and anticipated
for years star Chris Evans has been
forthcoming about the fact that his
contract is up and he wants to do other
things most fans expected Captain
America to died during Captain America
Civil War since that's what happened in
the comics so far though he's still
going strong but many expect Steve
Rogers to finally meet his end in
Avengers 4 and the anonymous 4chan
spoiler claims to know how it's going to
happen now one point Captain America and
Thor fight Thanos timeline alterations
have restored Mjolnir and cap wields
against Thanos to allow the others to
escape and this killed holding phallus
off these are just predictions and
rumors at this stage but the wake-ups
arc has been going seems to indicate
that he's going to go out with some kind
of grand sacrifice and dying in order to
save half a universe certainly fits the
bill Iron Man has a kid seeing as this
Avengers 4 leak came directly from the
mouth of Gwyneth Paltrow it seems almost
certain that Tony Stark will be a daddy
in Avengers 4 in an interview for the
official Avengers infinity war magazine
Paltrow revealed that a character Tony
Stark's longtime love interest Pepper
Potts was destined to become a mother
pepper and Tony have had a real long
journey together
she obviously stars as his dutiful
assistant and then the relationship
evolves and now this decade later
they're married and they have a child
their relationship has evolved in all
the ways that great romances evolve the
first question raised here is how did
the spoiler make it to print in an
official Marvel Magazine a second
question is does this mean there's going
to be a time jump sure the baby might be
born at the end of Avengers 4 as a
symbol of renewal and new life and if
that happens bet the house and the kid
being named Steven honor of Captain
America but it's also possible that
Avengers 4 start some years in the
future with Tony and Pepper already
parents if so at jumping back in time to
change the past could carry devastating
implications for Tony changing the
timestream might save half the
population of the universe but at the
cost of erasing his own child from
existence group shots in April 2018
Winter Soldier actor Sebastian Stan
accidentally dropped a spoiler for
Avengers 4 when he revealed there was a
scene featuring every character there
was one scene I think we had where
everybody was there I can't really talk
about that scene but I know it took them
three months and planning this scene to
have everyone there you look around and
you just saw everyone from samuel
l.jackson to michael douglas
to Michelle Pfeiffer everybody was there
Stan wasn't the only one who mentioned
filming the sequence either Scarlett
Johansson mentioned it as well during an
appearance on The Late Show with Stephen
Colbert one in particular scene there's
like thirty two of there's a lot there's
so many of us I don't even know who's a
Marvel character who's like a crew
member since there was no scene like
this in Avengers infinity war it must
take place in Avengers 4 and since
Winter Soldier and samuel l.jackson
snick fury both died from Thanos his
finger snap at infinity war we have to
wonder just how they managed to bring
everyone together at all hmm did Zoe
Saldana spoil the title Marvel Studios
head honcho made it clear early on but
the total of Avengers 4 was a closely
guarded secret but that went out the
window when Zoe Saldana seemed to
accidentally reveal the title of
Avengers 4 on the red carpet saying
infinity war is the first part and we
all have to go back for gauntlet later
this year Gunn told Yahoo that she
simply had a wires crossed it's not the
title my guess is that Zoe just misspoke
I'll talk to Zoe today but I would
imagine that is just Zoe miss speaking
and saying Infinity Gauntlet instead of
infinity war
Chand's anonymous tipster indicated that
this wasn't the case though right saying
the title was Avengers Infinity Gauntlet
at one point but it might be changed
after Zoe Saldana accidentally leaked
her back from the dead the fact that Tom
Hollands spider-man and chadwick boseman
black panther were wiped out by Thanos
despite both having sequels on the way
pretty much confirmed that at least some
of the departed heroes will be brought
back to life in Avengers for directors
Joe and Anthony Russo have been doing
their best to throw us off the scent by
implying that the mass deaths at the end
of infinity war are permanent but it's
hard to keep up that pretense when many
of the actors themselves are
contradicting them for instance Drax
actor Dave Bautista said I got a lot of
text saying I can't believe you're dead
he character is dead they were really
like heartbroken and I was like I'm
gonna be in for I'm gonna be in Guardian
stray I don't know how they're bringing
me back yet but somehow I'm gonna make
it because as far as I know I'm going to
be in Guardian 3 so I have to be back
and Zoe Saldana told alive from the red
carpet that being sacrificed by our
father Thanos don't like us see you
later rather than a true goodbye I knew
that we will have to all come back at
some point this fall and finish up the
fourth installment of Avengers we can't
wait to see how that finish plays out
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you're left a
[Music]